hey good morning everyone
um let's get started with uh for day
four and today we are very pleased to
have Randy Bryant talking about the
power of external resolution and explore
it
thank you so it's been an interesting uh
series of talks I've learned a lot and
um but I've come at this really as an
engineer who wants to build tools uh and
the one tool I've discovered recently
and I'll talk about is extended
resolution I'll I'll describe more about
what I mean by that
but my career a large part of my career
has been spent doing what I call formal
verification and this is just a subset
of the titles of some of my papers
um and the word formal verification
shows up a lot
but the honest truth is and so you can
think of the general principle of what
this is is you have some mathematical
description of a system
and you make some statements about Its
Behavior and you want to be able to
formally verify that's correct
but the truth is that the tools that
my students and I have developed over
the years always have this weakness that
what if there's a bug in the tool and in
fact you know there's a bug in the tool
because the big program and it's messy
uh and so you say I formally verified X
Y or Z but there's sort of that risk of
of somebody saying well
you know
I just found a bug in your tool oh shoot
I'll fix it rerun everything I did and
make sure it's not broken again
so uh that's not a totally satisfactory
feeling
uh and so of course there's been some
really interesting work on trying to
formally verify tools build tools that
were built on some Foundation of a
theorem prover or something like that
that you could argue is correct the
entire tool but the truth is that's
really hard to do and uh it's hard to
get performance out of tools of that
category so an alternative which I find
extremely attractive is to have a
checker that says I don't verify the
entire program I just verify individual
executions of the program
and the cool thing about that is once
you have that proof that you've
generated and it's checkable then even
if you find a bug in your original
solver you don't have to rerun it
because you have a proof that the
instance you ran before was okay and
that's a very powerful statement
and of course there's always the thing
aren't you just kicking the can down the
road what if there's a bug in the
Checker well there's two answers to that
one is that the Checker can be a much
simpler program
and uh based on a much simpler set of
rules and the second is it's actually
possible to have a formerly verified
Checker because it's a small enough uh
concise enough program with very clear
specification that formally verify it's
within the realm of possibility
so of course this is a well-established
idea in set solving that of course we
can always check if it's a solution if
it's satisfiable
and nowadays if it's unsatisfiable we
require the set solver to produce a
certificate of unsatisfiability
and this has become uh sort of very well
accepted my understanding of the history
is I remember when uh when Sharad first
put it into zchaf
and the reason he did I remember him
telling me was they'd found some working
bug in the set silver they'd been
running and many people had been using
for several years
and it really shook him up that his tool
was uh basically getting the wrong
answer but nobody had uncovered it and
so he put in a proof generation and
about the same time others put it in
other solvers uh but that was really
hard work to do because they didn't have
very good brief Frameworks for it and so
marine and his colleagues developed the
drap framework and uh efficient Checkers
for that that have now uh made it much
easier to take a a cdcl solver and just
with minor changes to it have it
generate uh proof Clauses and since 2016
that's been a mandatory for all the
entrants in the main track of the SAT
solving competition
and the impact of it is it's really
helped the solvers a lot that uh and
even the solver developers so now these
modern stat solvers are extremely
reliable and when they enter these
competitions and they're given totally
new benchmarks it's very rare for them
to actually fail
they'll produce the proofs and they're
quite reliable
and that's apparently the tool
developers have found this proof
checking extremely useful they put some
new features some in their thing they
generate a proof from that modified
feature and they find they can't do it
or they come up with a proof failure of
some sort and it gives them a very clear
identification of what's going wrong
so that's a sort of a theme of it is can
we add uh proof checking to other types
of tools and one of course is other
versions of sat solvers but also Beyond
set solvers where can this fit in uh as
well and uh so I'll talk some about
extended resolution and why that's
significant here and uh of course
given who I am it's Gotta involve bdds
at some level so uh and that's sort of
where I got excited about this was
realizing that bdds are actually very
powerful engines for generating uh
proofs
in extended resolution and more recent
work that we haven't published yet on
what's called knowledge compilation
which is a very interesting topic
we've seen uh resolution over and over
again but the idea of it is uh I think
is interesting to always remember that
it's really just a encoding of the idea
of logical implication
that you're combining two causes because
one implies the other and getting a
implication out of it and so a proof of
unsatisfiability and a causal proof is
then just a sequence of causes that you
append to the input formula where each
one has to preserve the satisfiability
of the formula procedure in other words
you can't add a new cause that turns an
unsatisfiable formula unsatisfied and
then the final cause is the MP cause
indicating that well the original
formula wasn't satisfiable in the first
place
resolution is a gives you a stronger
guarantee it's implication redundancy it
says that actually I'm not even my new
causes aren't even decreasing the set of
satisfying assignments to the formula so
when you get to the end you've you've
made a queer statement that there were
no satisfying assignments to the formula
so of course uh the way a causal proof
can look like then is that you give the
causes of the input formula and then
just start listing proof Clauses until
you derive the empty clause and each in
this uh sort of pure resolution style
each
um uh cause heads
uh two antecedents the the two causes
that were combined by resolution to
drive this cause and we keep doing this
systematically until we get an empty
clocks
so uh uh Gregory Satan introduced this
idea of extended resolution in 1967 and
I liked all those pictures and
biographies we were getting yesterday so
I did some research on Satan actually I
did it in 2020 and discovered that he
was in Leningrad at the what's now the
Saint Petersburg University of
Technology or something like that
um but he emigrated to the U.S in 1999
and worked for IBM
but unfortunately he died last year so
did you ever meet him oh yeah I know I I
met him in the 70s yeah because he was
hanging out at Stanford too right
so anyways um
but and he he actually worked mostly in
programming languages but his
contribution that we know most for is
this really simple idea that I can just
uh introduce a new variable called e an
extension variable into my proof and
then list a set of causes that encode
the the Formula E if and only if F where
f is an arbitrary Boolean formula over
the preceding the input variables and
the preceding uh uh extension variables
yeah
his version of it actually only you can
only build nand Gates essentially
uh but that's becomes now a shorthand
that you can use to sort of uh abstract
what otherwise might be a whole set of
Clauses and through repeated
applications this can uh make an
exponential difference
so in particular uh the idea would be
imagine we wanted to prove that this
formula was unsatisfiable and our
strategy was we want to encode u and v
as a sort of concrete object so we
introduce an extension variable that
encodes that
and now our proof becomes a listing of
input
causes uh definition causes and proof
causes uh but using the same pattern as
before and without going into the
details of this what you'll see is that
we're using that extension variable to
sort of rewrite all instances of unv
into e and then proving with respect to
e
so we've seen the variations on this
picture uh already several times that a
resolution then is the sort of
underlying logic of cdcl and it's better
than dpll which is just tree resolution
but there's this whole bunch of other
proof systems that are uh either
incomparable or stronger than resolution
until you get to the top is extended
Fraga but that's equivalent to Extended
resolution because as soon as you have
the power to build basically logic gates
you can build circuits and out of
circuits you can build things that
compute or you know serve as various
memos and other abstractions that you
can make use of and so that takes you
all the way top of the propositional
proof hierarchy in terms of what you can
do
so as an engineer I see that as an
opportunity it says that well our
current solvers are kind of down in the
basement here and yet we have this
little little thing that's built in and
it's supported by the existing proof
Checkers so why don't we make better use
of it
and that's sort of the idea of the talk
so as I said the the fact that cdcl is
is sort of uh
is down there with resolution what I
mean by that is uh they will
occasionally introduce a small modern
solvers will introduce some extension
variables during the pre-processing or
in processing step known as bounded very
variable addition where they rewrite
some of the causes by inserting
intermediate variables into it
and that's a useful thing but they don't
do it in at the level that you need to
to take an exponential thing and and get
it polynomial it's only a very minor
tweak in the overall thing there's been
a few people have tried to just well
let's kind of look for interesting stuff
and throw in extension variables as
we're chugging along in our cdcl solver
but those have really not been
successful
so there's this uh technique that's out
there that everyone has understood but
nobody's really had or a few people have
had very good ideas on how to use it
because
um in some ways it's such a simple idea
and such a powerful idea there's no
obvious way to turn that into
essentially working solver
and um
so just as an example uh this is uh I
find a really interesting Benchmark it
just basically says a set of variables
has both even an odd parity at the same
time
uh we'll make it a little bit less
trivial by using a random permutation on
one of those so that it's not a perfect
uh matching between the two
uh but anyways it's not hard to see this
is not satisfiable
but if I feed this to a a very good
um
set solver keysight sort of the best
there is in cdcl you'll see that it
really struggles I've I should show my
complexity here in terms of proof causes
but the same picture shows if I show
time that in fact I limited the time
here to 600 seconds and I couldn't get
Beyond n equals 42 and of course I tried
a few random permutations to make it not
uh to give some a sense of sampling
but it's really not there
and so one way to think about this is if
you imagine in a sort of uh not clear
what your metrics are but if you think
about some problems are easy in the
mathematical sense and some are hard
and cdcl solvers can nail some problems
but really struggle on others
uh in this kind of vague fuzzy sense of
things what's been interesting about
modern sat solvers is that they're they
if you're right at the limits of their
performance you can solve some
interesting problems some problems that
are interesting to some people mainly
practitioners who use these tools to
verify circuits and other things and
some amount of mathematical proofs that
people haven't been able to do otherwise
yeah
Perry equations on the other hand are
down in this end right these are ones
that are super hard for cdcl solvers but
conceptually from a mathematical point
of view it's as trivial as you could ask
similarly pigeonhole mutilated
chessboard and these are problems you
could describe to a child and the child
would go well you can't solve that
problem
but yet the cdcl solvers solve it so
it's really and in fact they're so hard
that they hardly even have benchmarks
for these in the SAT solver competitions
anymore because they serve no purpose in
distinguishing solver X from solver y
since neither of them can solve these
problems right
so anyways we sort of glossed over the
fact that cdcl has these glaring
weaknesses and I thought it was
interesting the way Karen described that
pigeonhole really shows up in real life
like when you're trying to Route wires
through a channel uh that's exactly
where you encounter so these aren't just
artificial problems that were made up to
to prove theorems about
so bring in bdbs
um the idea of using bdds as a proof
generating solver actually was started
with work by Carstens and Armin beer and
Tony yusua back in 2006.
and the idea of it is really powerful
and I kind of picked up on this
um early in the pandemic and started
working on this topic
um and got pretty excited by it and
that's the area I've carried along since
then working with mine
but the idea of it is very simple that
we'll introduce a bdd uh extension
variable for every node in a bdd and in
code as the defining causes what that
node means and then generate a proof
steps but the proof steps really encode
the sort of underlying bdd algorithm the
recursion that goes on
foreign
and so the idea of this then once you
kind of get that then the rest is just
working out the details that you say the
sort of standard bdd operation is to
take two bdds u and v and some Boolean
connectives say or
and generate a bdd representing that new
function
and the idea of it is this recursion
that starts at every uh given a pair of
nodes u and v will then recursively
descend and generate uh sub graphs for
the two uh case where X is false in the
case where X is true
and then join those together potentially
with a new node uh labeled by X and of
course there's a lot of special cases
but that's the main one so the idea with
this is we'll introduce here an
extension variable and then four causes
that basically say U is equivalent to
the if then else of uh X Nu 1 and U zero
where you want a new zero know the
extension variables for the children so
that's four clauses
and then uh each proof step in addition
to generating a new node each recursive
column addition to generating a new node
will also generate a sequence of proof
steps leading to the implication that
UND implies w
and you can see that if you imagine so
that's our goal
but you can see if if we recursively
assume that the two recursive calls
generated proofs of their outcomes
then we can just do a resolution of the
those two recursive results with the
defining pauses for the relevant nodes
and get the proof for our our
our uh our node here and we just keep
doing that that information just gets
carried along as the bdd's tug away
we're just spitting out proof steps that
are basically on a very very low level
uh describing or justifying the
underlying logic of the bdd algorithm
and so uh we do this and all of a sudden
now this uh Benchmark looks a lot
simpler we can push out to close to 10
000. uh with uh reasonable proof sizes
and using a very automated and simple
technique known as bucket elimination
which is just a way of systematically
um
forming conjunctions of bdds and then
quantifying out variables
so these extension variables are
basically the outputs of the
multiplexers that represent that PDD
node right yep exactly so it's like
we're just naming the signals in a
circuit representation of BDT is that
that's exactly it
You're Building circuits and then you're
proving properties of those circuits and
that's a good way to think about it
um but it's interesting to compare now
if we compare a resolution proof from
cdcl versus a proof generated with bdds
they're really different in a
quantitative sense that the cdcl3 of
what it's generating is conflict cause
it's saying this part of the search
space is not reachable so just block
that off
and over time you're forming this
conjunction of those until you come up
with the empty set
a bdd proof is more I've done this
recursive call and it's consistent with
what I told you it would do right at a
small level done
too much I want to slow you down too
much but but I want to make sure I I I I
get this so so you've got uh uh these
Clauses and and you start out uh on one
hand uh uh you you form a bdd that
for x uh plus x x 1 plus X2 and you also
and and then you add that into uh then
you gotta also X1 uh
at what point do
do you assert the parody of it oh okay
so the CNF I'm working with has already
encoded these xores using Satan
variables right it's already a it's a so
it's just I'm going right from CNF here
okay and uh so encoded this parity
formulas are encoded using the sort of
standard encodings of xor's in there
and so now but the question you
you could have asked but you didn't how
do you go from CNF to bdds okay and the
answer is for each cause you can
you can actually generate a bdd
representation of that cause very easily
right as this sort of very simple linear
structure and you can generate a proof
that the root of that is implied by that
particular input clause
uh by just uh one sequence of resolution
steps and so now I have a bdd
representation of each clause and I
start forming conjunctions and
quantifying out variables and I keep
doing that over and over again until in
the end I end up with the leaf node zero
and that's the empty clause
any other questions
right
uh so this chart actually shows an
interesting phenomena related to that
that
even though I'm generating proofs that
are totally compatible with the standard
um uh Checker you know drap proves the
um they're really different that one is
really more at the problem level
describing how you're what you're doing
with the search space whereas the other
is more the algorithm level justifying
an algorithm but it's kind of cool to me
that these can all be handled within the
same proof framework I don't have to
have a special proof Checker just for me
to do
um and so you'll notice is one
consequence is that the you don't
generate proof steps as often in cdcl as
you do and because you do all that other
stuff until you hit a conflict
and here we're generating up to six uh
proof steps for every recursive call but
um
they're not the it's not that huge a
difference in size factors
another for a few uh hackers you'll
notice that the time per free step for
smaller benchmarks is like just below
one microsecond and for larger ones it's
about two
and the reason for that increase is just
the overhead of garbage collection and
all the other stuff that a bdd package
has to do
question
yeah so you say that cbcl uh indicates
reduction in search space I am so see
this here
because reduction in search space I
understand that very well but I don't
understand what you mean by bdd proof
steps justify algorithmic steps well in
other words you have this intuition the
apply algorithm is just this recursive
algorithm that builds a new bdd based on
some existing ones and what we're
saying is an invariant property of what
those what that how that algorithm Works
in terms of what each recursive call
returns and we're building a proof
that's basically just stringing together
this long sequence of of algorithmic
steps into a proof that will end up
being a proof of unsatisfiability
that's yeah a tiny question uh the
y-axis here is solver runtime not
Checker runtime
oh yeah I have a different one on
Checker runtime oh exciting but I don't
have it with me but the Checker is a
little faster per cause because I
generate lrat if you got those know the
file formats lrat includes hints for
each Clause all the other causes that it
depends on
whereas drat doesn't have hints and you
have to run a drap proof through drap
trim which is incredibly fast but it
takes time so it's almost as if these
two flip and the outcome is about the
same
so which are the variables you're
quantifying here all of them
all the input variables so right because
I'm reducing it to the
I could by the way in principle just
it's just an and it's just this giant
conjunction I could in principle just
build up a bdd representation of the
whole thing and not use quantification
at all but the intermediate bdds would
explode
so what you want to do is is as
aggressively as possible quantify away
existentially quantify away variables
and you do that by uh you know having
some ordering to the
uh variables and always a quantif
forming a conjunction that for which one
the next variable
so it's a unique because you do early
quantification right okay but it's all
uh totally automated it doesn't require
any
in fact it can be done using random
variable orderings So when you say no
quantification that oh this is from
other benchmarks yeah the point was this
is from another paper where I tried a
whole bunch of different things and got
vastly different proof sizes for the
same problem and all this was showing
was regardless of
of what kind of style of of uh
generation I was doing with the bdds the
it's a totally fixed uh rate at which it
generates proof causes because it's
based on the individual steps the
algorithm
so so Randy the original DP algorithm
was essentially quantifying the
variables what you're doing is just
adding extension variables in that
process is that what's going on yeah
so I'm not doing
because that also explodes in the middle
right as you do the existence I'm not
really doing DP yeah I mean at some
level you're doing GP but I'm just
wondering if you added the extension
variable introduction to these things as
you do these extent the exists on the
input variables what would would DP then
become viable
you're solving the problem you saw
you're trying to show that the
anti-clause isn't saved by the uh
so uh moving on that was an interesting
exercise but uh oh a question yes so why
would you first transform match Source
into CNF instead of just using the
DirecTV representation of actual I did
transfer these are all cnf2s
everything's cnf3 okay I thought the
problem was about parity yeah but encode
use your favorite way of encoding a
parity problem in CNN thank you thanks
sorry I didn't
go back through that but everything here
I'm working I'm starting with CNF
um so now let's move on that uh the
truth is so if you btds are great at
some problems but really lousy at others
and if you try to just like start
solving uh sat Benchmark competition
problems you pretty much get nowhere it
just doesn't compete uh but there's
other interesting classes of formulas
that now that I have this engine this
essentially proof engine I could use it
independent of how I actually do the
derivation and by that I mean I've
become very intrigued by this idea of
pseudobullion formulas which are linear
equations or inequalities where the
coefficients are integers but the
variables are just zero one value and as
I show here they can be equations
constraints or actually modular and the
case of of Radix 2 of course they're
parity constraints so those are very
interesting in in many applications
um and one thing BDT is love
um pseudobuyan formulas meaning this is
uh well not
let me love is too strong a term
um if the coefficients are small
then the bdds are small so you end up
with this uh rule here that the largest
bdd will be the absolute value of
largest coefficient times N squared and
that's independent variable order you
don't have to be clever about this at
all
so for the case where the coefficients
are reasonably small this is a good
number of course the the coefficients
can grow to be exponential in size given
a a bit level encoding of them and so
potentially they could explode on you so
this is actually what you'd call a
pseudo-polynomial bound on a pseudobuyan
function even though those have nothing
to do with each other the two pseudos
um
uh and it's much better for a modular
equations that you have this very simple
representation that's it where the width
of it is most the Radix are
so imagine you've got some terribly
clever uh pseudobuyan solver
and um
you have some way that to get from
however you've encoded let's assume CNF
and you can extract out of that or
somebody tells you where these
pseudobuyan formulas and how they're
encoded in the CNF and so we could uh in
principle given a a formula that's
suitably a suitable formula we could do
uh an infeasibility check using the
pseudobuyan solver
um and there's a lot of very interesting
ways to do that
the problem with that picture is where's
the proof right people don't really
trust now one thing about uh sat solvers
is if you can't prove a formula is
untrue then it's no longer people don't
believe you anymore
um so here's the idea that
um I did with along with Armin Pierre
last year and command of course too
which is uh kind of hang a box on the
side a bdd engine and the bdd engine is
not going to be used for the kind of
core reasoning that's being done by the
pseudobuyan solver it's just being using
it to spit out a sequence of proof steps
that will justify the the pseudobuyan
solvers operations so in particular I
have to do two things I have to prove
that the pseudobuyan constraints that
are extracted out of that are truly uh
implied by the input causes
and the other is for each low level step
of this solver I have to be able to
justify that it preserves
its implication preserving basically
and so out of that and then I'll end up
just deriving a a refutation proof on it
so the the point being that the BD Gates
here are just uh an assistant here
they're not actually doing the reasoning
itself
and the the key idea of that is
um you have to break down the solver
into some very primitive steps for
example it might be given two
constraints of add them together
so in general you'll have some operation
on two constraints that generates a
third constraint and what you have to do
is just prove that their respective bdds
the end of the two argument bdds implies
the uh
the
um
newly generated bdd
and the complexity of that is sort of
the product of the three bdd sizes
so as long as the coefficients say small
this will be a nice polynomial operation
and so if we do that for our parity
problems you know parity is the best
because it's these bounded width of bdgs
and so the extremely fast and so using
gaussian elimination on those parity
constraints we can just fly through this
and it breaks
uh when n gets so large when this number
of variables get so large that it
overflows the field in the bde package
that encodes variables so I could
recompile it to use more but the point
being that this is now clearly a trivial
problem for um where this uh approach to
solution right we've totally blown it
away
yes
yes you encode the entire the entire
diagram
well the variable for the root
describes the entire diagram
and like Karen said think of it as a
circuit representation of of that
buoyant function
exactly
so this bdd based uh proof generation
strategy seems to work for any rewrite
rule
is that correct
um if you can break it down to
yeah A Primitive step like this
rewriting some right hand side to an
equivalent left hand side yes exactly
that's a good way to think about it okay
foreign
so I I think that's again
it relies on you know having a problem
domain for which these bdds uh stay
reasonably compact otherwise of course
it doesn't work at all but at least in
the pseudobullion case that uh seems to
be true to at least for some classic
problems
um so the way I describe this then is
what we've shown that is sort of bdds
can help you clean up these really
glaring weaknesses but it's not showing
you that you can solve any problems that
one would consider mathematically
interesting
um yes
so so the department is satisfied and it
has eliminated variables
to
[Music]
established liability
to get Witnesses for those eliminated
variables oh that's easy to do
a back substitution on it and reverse
order yeah
in fact you can
um it's fairly cool that you can
generate multiple Witnesses by just
essentially you know generating a
solution by this back substitution
blocking that one and doing it again and
you can just keep enumerating them over
and over again
and this by the way can be used also not
just for onset but for um
well I get I guess if it's satisfiable
then all this doesn't really matter
right that having the proof generation
does annoy meth let's think it's
something else so
um but you know someday what we'd really
like to do is get here we'd like to do
interesting problems that can't be done
alone with cdcl
um but some other tool possibly would do
that
and I honestly don't have the answer to
[Music]
um
but it seems like one approach would be
what I'll call cdcl of T which is not an
smt solver it's saying let's have
multiple cause reasoning engines for
buoyant problems and be able to run them
on different uh parts of the problem and
coordinate their activities by having
them exchange unit
propagations and conflicts
uh just like an smt solver works and the
one instance of this uh that I know of
is crypto mini set of course which has
built into it both a causal part and a
Gauss Jordan elimination part
uh and so it can uh
at least take two different of these
engines and operate them together
um it's harder than you know it's easy
to draw the picture and hard to
implement the code
especially deciding how to coordinate
between them it's really tricky and of
course you you know they're they're very
different engines in terms of
cdcl runs really really fast in its
inner loop uh but doesn't get you very
far on each step whereas uh Gauss Jordan
is doing these big uh you know
elimination steps so there's sort of a
lot of coordination issues but one thing
mache and I did last year was show that
we could sort of attack a bdd package
onto his parity solving code and use it
to generate proofs because before that
crypto mini set could uh when given an
unset problem couldn't generate proofs
if it was using its ghost Jordan engine
so it was an interesting uh experience
that I think showed that it can be done
but it's hard to do it
that's not that easy to do
it'd be interesting to build in other
solvers into this so I think this is uh
If part of this talk is here's some
interesting research Direction you might
think of this is definitely high on my
list for you
so uh the latest work we've done and
this is hasn't been published yet
uh but it's in the topic of what's
called knowledge compilation which
I don't know why it's called knowledge
compilation it to me they're just
buoyant formulas but
it's the idea of it is you CNF it's
really hard to say much about it in
particular it's very hard to count
models or you know say
uh
anything about it and so what we want to
do is transform that CDC NF into a
representation for which things like
model counting become very simple and of
course there's going to be a possible
exponential blow up because it's a sharp
Peak set
issue but what's remarkable to me is
that there are programs out there in
particular we've been using one called
D4 which is incredibly uh successful at
and it's based on a sort of cdcl style
but it builds up a
essentially a circuit representation of
this formula for Which accounting
becomes easy
so just to go into it a little more but
the problem you have with that is just
like a SAT solver it it returns this box
that you can query and answer questions
about but how are you sure that that box
you created is logically equivalent to
the input formula and then
I make these queries and even if I trust
that representation how do I make sure
that you know it computed things like
the number of models correctly
so that's the the general context here
um I like a formulation of paper I read
by kimig and her co-authors that
describe this as algebraic model
Counting and what they'd say is imagine
a a a set of total total assignment will
just be viewed as a set of n literals
signing a value to each input variable
and so a model as you know is the set of
all possible satisfying assignments for
the formula
but now let's map this uh
uh
into a commutative ring where what I
want to do is compute I'll say that the
there's a weight associated with each
variable
and the weight of its negation is one
minus that
and that the weight of a uh assignment
then it's the product of the weights
it's good rules and the value of the
overall formula is the sum of the
weights of its uh satisfying assignments
so in particular with this definition I
can do model counting in the following
way I assign one-half to each variable
and what I'll get out of that when I run
this uh ring evaluation is I'll get uh
the density the fraction of assignment
of possible assignments that satisfy
this formula so if I just scale that by
2 to the N I'll get the count of the
number of models
or if you imagine the weight being a
probability
between zero and one then the computed
value of this will be the probability
that the formula is true
so there's a lot of other stuff you can
do with this model it's really a a
pretty uh a handy thing
and the the main thing this is uh as far
as I can tell all model counters rely on
this principle that if I can
represent a buoyant formula in this
following very restricted form I say
that
I'll only perform conjunctions over
cases where the two sub formulas are
over disjoint sets of variables
and only do the disjunction over two
formulas where they have disjoint models
then uh basically then I can argue that
the set of satisfying assignments to a
conjunction will be the cross product of
the and and so the ring evaluation will
be the product
and they uh set of satisfying
assignments to a disjunction will be
their disjoint Union and so again I get
a sum over this ring and negation comes
for free you just do one minus to get
that
so
um these model counters um knowledge
compilers come at with various
idiosyncratic file formats but at the
core what they're doing is just
representing a formula that obeys these
restrictions for all its conjunctions
and disjunctions and potentially as
negations uh on the edges in uh in
arbitrary places
so this is a an example of of what they
might produce in my own uh way of
describing it
um so what we've developed and uh is a
tool chain that will take uh the output
of a knowledge compiler and convert it
to this form which I call a Pog which of
course is an acronym in search of a a
meaning but a nice easy one to pronounce
so partitioned operation graph and what
it will produce is a file that both
encodes that graph and uh provides a
proof justifying that the uh POG is
logically equivalent to the input
formula and I'll talk about what that
means and how we do it and then checking
becomes twofold one is we want to make
sure that that equivalence holds and the
other is we want to be able to safely do
this ring evaluation over this uh
representation
but we've shifted the again like before
we've shifted The Trusted base to be on
the checking side away from uh you know
a very complex knowledge compiler and a
fairly complex proof generator
and if you don't uh trust our trusted
code well I've got even something better
for you which is a really trusted
version of it uh that uh our the
graduate student who worked with us on
this was able to write a lean four which
is a proof system uh
a a version of checkers for this and
ring evaluation that is uh guaranteed is
formally verified
and actually this was for those who have
ever worked on I found this a very
interesting exercise first of all made
me appreciate how hard it is to prove
things that we kind of just say well
it's a ring fine it's no problem right
um
but also it exposed some weaknesses we
had to add a few more conditions and
rules nothing major but some very subtle
points that we'd overlooked that that
only uncovered when he couldn't get the
proofs to go through so it's a if you're
ever devising your own proof format or
Checker this is a useful exercise
um so what does it mean to prove
equivalence well uh let's say
that the formula is a set of causes Phi
sub I and what I'll how I'll Define the
POG logically is using extended
resolution I'll say that there's a
extension variable for every node in
this graph
or every operator in this graph and it
will have its defining causes according
to whether it's an Android or operation
and I can introduce negation by just
allowing uh the inputs to an argument to
be literals not just variables
uh and I'll so that that there'll be a
set of unit causes that basically
defines
this circuit and then I'll say and
there's a unit cause
uh for the the root node and that
combination of these defining Clauses in
that unit cause what they say is any
assignment that satisfies the input
formula uh
will satisfy this
circuit you know produce a one on this
circuit and vice versa right it's a if
not we we have to prove equivalent to
not just uh One Direction here
and so the the proof of that actually is
two different proofs one is a forward
implication proof that every assignment
to the formula will generate a a one on
this circuit and similarly that
uh
conversely basically anything that would
falsify one of the causes will also
produce a zero on that circuit is what
the reverse implication proof looks like
and so the forward one looks kind of
standard uh
resolution steps based on the circuit
structure you can imagine what it looks
like the reverse one's interesting in
that the way you approve satisfaction in
a causal framework is you delete the
causes and you have to justify that each
deletion doesn't somehow enable some new
assignments to to come through and
satisfy what's left of the conjunction
and so what you do is you build up this
proof and then you start deleting
Clauses you delete away all the ones
that were used
in the implications that you built up
you don't delete the unit Clause at the
top and then you start deleting input
clauses
foreign
each time you delete it you're saying
anything that would falsify that input
cause will also falsify my output done
yeah
when you say class you uh you you mean
CNF yeah my whole world so so where does
the Restriction about you you know
taking only the Andover disjoint
variables and uh or over
where does that occur in this it doesn't
occur in the proof that that's not a
necessary part of the proof
it's a necessary part of the um
uh representation to be able to do ring
evaluation so there's separate proof
obligations
on the for the disjoint that the the
other part of this uh file format is for
every time I do an or I have to give a
set of uh essentially a very small
resolution proof that says these two are
a mutually exclusive
and those are checked and then the the
disjointness of the conjunctions you can
do by just keeping track of the
dependency sets for all the intermediate
I thought that was going to be the hard
part no that's right you right you can
do that I could usually
keep track of what variables I've used
so so the conjunction was the hard part
but the disjunction why is that oh
because I give a resolution proof that
we'll show those are mutually that show
that there's nothing in common right
okay and in this case the value is
produced by these model counters it's
trivial because the disjunction occurs
when they branch on a variable and they
explore the case of the variable true
and the variable false okay and then
just four those together so there's a
single variable
yeah okay but but that's part of the one
of the proof obligations
but this the equivalence proof doesn't
rely on either of those properties
but the the point being that we're so
used to talking about refutation proofs
and resolution but they're also equally
capable of doing satisfaction proofs by
this is if you can justify in a in a
proof framework where you have to
justify each cause to wish
so we ran this uh tool we developed on
uh benchmarks from last year's uh sat uh
I'm sorry model counting competition
and um of the 180 unique uh Benchmark
files that we started with uh D4 could
complete 124 of them
uh using a four thousand time limit and
then we allowed the proof generation
excuse me up to ten thousand seconds
uh and then let the Checker run as long
as it needed to run
so uh what you see is these are um
uh these are some pretty serious
benchmarks sorry this even though this
was a prototype tool of sorts and you'll
see that the time run by the um
the proof generator would be
typically factors of 10 more than the D4
runtime uh there were a few cases where
it actually ran faster than D4 which is
interesting but um we were able to do
total
two-sided proofs for 108 of them
and we could only do the reverse
implication side we could do that for
nine more of them the reverse
implication is a simple proof generation
uh and then there were just seven of
them left that we couldn't uh get
anywhere on we either timed out or ran
out of space
but just to give a sense of of sizes
um
it's we're not small right that the
number of defining causes in generated
by D4 went up to 2.7 billion in fact
overflowed the 32-bit number I had to on
track cause IDs
and we were able we weren't able to
generate a proofs for any of the inputs
that went over a billion uh defining
Clauses but we were able to do some that
were in the hundreds of millions of them
and you'll see that the proof size is is
sort of Highly varied but there's a Big
Blob of them that are roughly three
times larger the proof than the the
defining causes and then there's some
that are basically very hard to satisfy
formulas so very small number of models
and the proof had to encode sort of all
the unset conditions in that result
hmm
so that just shows an example of what I
like about this work too is that you
think model counting oh you've got to
reason about numbers in addition and
blah blah blah but this idea of
going through knowledge compilation
first which most model counters do
either explicitly or implicitly
um then that's a pure Boolean problem
and that's a sort of harder to lift
in terms of the program because once you
have it in that representation then the
counting part of it becomes simple and
for my colleagues who did the mean
proofs of it that that was the easy part
of the proof the the the Boolean part
was the hard part of it so
um the point being that this even causal
proofs are useful for more than just
pure buoyant problems the problems that
on the face might seem uh more than pure
bullied
so uh just to recap then the um
I think this idea of
of uh checkable proofs is extremely
powerful and it has this effect by the
way that it's very habit-forming in the
sense that once you've seen this
capability in one tool you want it
everywhere else and I think a lot of
people in this room have felt that way
on the other hand since the choir we're
most of us are researchers you know
having more problems to solve
um as John hooker said it's just part of
guaranteed employment even for those of
us who are retired
uh but also I think one thing is uh I've
learned too is that the causal
Frameworks that were established and
well known are extremely powerful and
it's kind of useful if you can work
within that framework so for example our
generator makes calls to catacol makes
calls to g-rat trim you know it's making
use of these causal reasoning tools that
are available to us and uh can kind of
uh all work together
uh
and there's other places that I didn't
have a chance to go into but these
clever places where we insert lemmas
into the proof as a way of handling the
case of nodes in the graphs that have
multiple ancestors so we don't have to
expand that graph into a tree and
potentially have an exponential flow up
there
so there's all kinds of cool once you
get the hang of extended resolution you
can sort of build little boxes to do
this and that it's a lot of fun
okay so that's
so I didn't know Satan had to do with
programming languages and I've been
trying to remember where I saw this they
have this thing called ghost variables
and programming languages I can't
remember the paper
I can't I don't remember that he's
mentioned there no because he I don't
think that's what he's known for
so I but they talk about ghost variables
which seem like extension videos Satan
left behind all interest in logic at
some point in his life and became a
programming language person and never
looked back yeah but Don would know
better than I do and by the way if you
want to look around you have to look at
there's various different romanizations
of his name yes yes
with the Y and stuff and so you have to
look at different romanizations to pick
up everything but the notion of
extension variables appears in other
fields like ghost variables definitions
yes things like this you know where you
just label some complex formula and then
use it yeah go variables is a very
interesting idea
is that
there's one a remarkable thing about the
the way you approach this knowledge
compilation namely that you're not
um certifying what the four is doing
actually but you're taking its output
and creating a proof when it's finished
right
um have you considered doing it directly
in there and are there well have you
ever looked at the code for D4
uh no I'm I'm joking but you're right
that's an interesting property that
we're just taking it like it you know
wrote off the truck and then we're just
starting to look at it
um we are relying little that we know
that there's some
aspects of it in particular we we know
that every time there's an or there's
going to be a variable that it's
splitting over
and
um also it's in a negation normal form
so the only Compliments are on the
leaves and we're making use of that
stuff but we're not making use of any of
the internal structure and does this
mean that the tool doesn't work for
General ddnmfs but only those that have
this specific property of branching well
or first of all uh I don't know if you
know D4 has its own idiosyncratic file
format and I haven't implemented the one
for the other more common format but I
did do a little bit of evaluation of
there's a program called D sharp which
is sharp sat modified to produce ddnfs
and it works fine for those
so it's not restricted in other words
all knowledge compilers that I know of
all top-down knowledge compilers that I
know of
effectively uh use obey those same set
of rules for for what kind of ddns they
produce
right they're always branching on a
variable
and they're always starting with well
the nnf stands for negation normal form
there so
so there's this DD nnf right with a
small D and the capital D and there I
think it's a semantic condition saying
that the two branches of the ore
cannot be simultaneously satisfied right
even if they shared a common variable
right there's actually two if you look
at darwish's papers
not only does he have a lot of acronyms
but there's double meanings for some of
the acronyms so the first D can mean
either decision or deterministic
decision means he's a single variable
use but undeterministic just simply
means that they're mutually exclusive
so so the so if I were given by the way
a more General one I'd just call a SAT
solver there to prove that it's their
their uh uh the mutual exclusion
no
all right or here
so I had the I found your idea really
interesting when you're talking about
like how to approve parity formulas and
you essentially what I understood is you
have you take your Clauses you turn them
into bdds and then you merge them yes
but and then the order in which you
merge them is very important for for
your algorithm right
um well it's sort of like if you know
how spouse Express
um you know gaussian elimination solvers
works with pivot selection I I use
strategies like that okay
um did you find any bugs no I'm curious
oh no that's an interesting thing with
D4 I haven't found a single pug in it
it's really amazing because
I never would have expected it it's a
pretty fancy piece of code and I haven't
found any bugs in it
you could maybe also try to use Sharps
at TV
because you can use it as an algebraic
model counter
right you can plug inside doesn't
produce uh representation but sharp said
CD has these templates you can plug in
you know
change the same earrings it works on yes
so you could get the uh I can do a
comparison yeah yeah
you know dtdns from it
yeah well yes I'll look at other so you
know as you know when you're trying to
get something done need a paper deadline
you have to
decide what you're going to do and what
you're not going to do so
G4 by my the small experiments I ran D4
was just killing everyone else so and it
it was in the model counting competition
of all the knowledge compilation based
ones I think the topic
no
you can you can get the traces right
like from
dark side and shops at cvso right so
these are all doable things uh and I I'm
not saying I won't do them
yeah well I think yes
did you did you try sightings
that's 19's problem on on parity ground
oh yes so I didn't show it but all the
Satan formula is over graphs in
particular the standard Benchmark was
devised by worker hard uh based on
expanded graphs
to show a lower bound resolution proof
of an extremely small formula
and uh so back in the first sat
competition me I forget its first name
from France submitted a formula of the
Satan foreign
formula with the the parameter is called
m
equals three which is the smallest
possible instance of that formula and
back then none of the solvers could deal
with it
it was included in the anniversary track
last year
and guess what none of the solvers could
do it the smallest instance extremely
small formula like 800 Clauses or
something like that
and it just absolutely kills them so we
can do
work our heart up to
m equals 200 and something and the
formulas grow quadratically with them so
they're pretty easy
if you think about anything you can do
any kind of parity reasoning you can do
and go really fast
yeah yeah I mean it's just a remark on
the D4 kills it which I think is
probably right in case you just run it
on CNF I think what's kind of
counter-intuitive or kind of painful is
that current set of like mobile counters
sometimes you need to run a
pre-processing tool either B plus C or
arjune or something otherwise it gets um
stuck unfortunately so that's I mean
it's very counterintuitive and like it's
a bunch of shell scripts that
everybody's running so that needs to be
solved to be honest and that would be
very interesting because as if I was
pointing out I'm just solving I'm
looking at the artifact that's produced
so if you've run it through all kinds of
crud you know I can still feed it into
my tool and presume we get some results
so that would be some very interesting
experiments to do
okay on that note Let's uh conclude this
thank Randy again
uh we had 21 minutes we meet at 11 so